これはある sns 投稿が巻き起こした
一条西トム怖い話
そういえばこの投稿みた何肇社長が約
ん
[音楽]
アプ minaわかるプールみたいだよ
ねー
あってかさこの投稿を見た肇社長が薬物
使用してるってやつ
はじめしゃちょー所そうそうはじめしゃ
ちょーお薬やってるらしいぐっすり
なわけないでしょ
この投稿だけ見て示したん
新作とかしてみたいやしてないけど
you一旦確認した方がいいとまあまあ
そっか
肇社長や9分
follow
あああん
これフェイクだようそ
これ昔のドッキリ動画からそれっぽい
ところを切り取ってるだけだよ a
しかもこのアカウント前にも芸能人につい
て嘘の発信してるみたいじゃんって言う
まじでん
わざわざアカウントのことなんて見て
なかっただめだよちゃんと確認しないと
そこ
滝のような汗かいてるじゃんああいやあ
これを今の普通に滝に打たれてるからいや
それは無理あるよ滝に打たれてるわけない
じゃないか何そんなに合わせて痩せては
ないけど
う
拡散しちゃった花がたくさん
twitter に流れてきてうんリ
ツイートしちゃったからリツイートし
ちゃったん
いやだめだよをちゃんと確認しないとあー
でもその後恋のがバナナに怯えている動画
もリツイートしたから大丈夫だから関係
ないよかわいい色が率維持したからって
その許されないと思います
子タグも付いてるからどんどん拡散され
てるじゃんうわほんとだだめだよちゃんと
他の情報も検索したりして判断しないと
そっか
あみんな行く登校だったよ動作急に叫んで
どうした拡散しようと思って原始的すぎる
よやり方が調べずに拡散してどんどん大変
なことになっちゃってるからとにかくなん
とかしないとと思っていえーいやり方が
違うあっどうしたまたなんかしちゃったん
ぐらーかでも拡散しちゃったぁー
裏おかあ持ってたんだって
あなんかしたらまた塾の皆に入っちゃった
まだ塾行ってるんだあ
洗濯物取り込んでくるのですがそれは関係
ないよあ
警察に電話しちゃったよ
それはやばいねまじでん
えっ
ヤバイことになってる
こんなフェイク統合あるの
霊授く警察に電話したったの
マジかよ
やばいやばいやばい
[音楽]
ん
みんなや薬物をやってないよ
はじめに地絡かのにお前かコメント喜多方
ない誰だよ
させ演じられてるよ
かつやってるとか三役だよ
もうすぐちさせてくださいん
まあ何
でしょ
ヤバイ事になってんぞ
[音楽]
んだよ
偵察だ
ガーン
はい葛藤を拭けるだねぇ
ソース程度でえっ
はい通りで今回ですねまじまりばりーさん
と一緒に動画を作らせていただいたわけな
んですけれども
あの動画はピクションです
あれはもう嘘で西区の動画でございます
実際にですフェイクニュースを信じて
しまってそれを拡散したりしてしまうと
大変な目に遭いますのでぜひ皆さんきょう
つけてください僕みたいないます本当に
に受勲
ため君ありがとうございましたを使い
がとうございましたでした
すごい味の社長だものだはじめまして
僕はやはりまにぃさんの大ファンなんです
よでも動画3つ見てて
動画
不可能が垂れるのを誰か設定そそうですね
いません難しい設定でああいうイレパネ
尾根文ませんのタイプも僕ちょうだい婚約
かなもので遺影や全然上手です本当に思っ
てますあれですよ
なんで上から
う
経験者こういうので慣れ卵だそうですはい
や2と多分本当に起きたらもっとアー
ティフため区と思うんですけど
本当にまた来こういうことにならないよう
に教室ましょうお気を付けます
間違った情報が拡散されたことで知らない
間に誹謗中傷なで苦しむ人傷つく人社会的
な信用をなくす事態に陥ってしまうなど
大きな影響を及ぼすので気をつけましょう
はいうんっ些細な行動ひとつでここまで
大きな影響が出るかもしれないなんて本当
に気をつけないとだね上方への接し方を
しっかり理解することが大事ですはい重宝
へのフェチ方をしっかり理解していること
が大事ですぼくいました簡単に言うと大事
です簡単にすぎですちょっと友達に伝える
だけでもですねぞう方は一人歩きして
しまっておがーで方向に行ってしまうこと
もあります google が提供して
いる無料のトレーニングプロジェクト
pro with googleて勉強し
ましょういろんな情報の確かめ方を紹介し
てくれます
ao o
ということですね枚 bally バリー
さんの山の上の方でもコラボさせて
いただいておりますのでそちらの動画も
ぜひチェックしてみてくださいおこれは
本当ですお願いします
[音楽]